you can't let him cry son it always
sounds bad what surprised you the most
about one another when you got on set
I've been told by many of our mutual
friends that he's a nice guy in the
world and and that by the way is his
reputation internationally every other
was surprised but it was just like a
confirmation yeah you know just being a
fan of your work and then to actually
see it in person and have the honor of
playing together and to tell a story
together it was just like oh my gosh you
are really really really good she's
everything she's cracked up to be yeah I
read stick to the strategy in real life
the strategy doesn't include social
media neither of the a-listers have
accounts connecting them with their fans
is there a reason behind this I might
just be lazy
and think that it's too much of a
commitment I'd like to post things I
don't know that um that tweeting is
always a safe bet you know depending on
how emotional your day is and we get you
on there we want to see the behind the
scenes you have it don't you think a
little mystery is a good idea for me I
guess it's privacy yeah that's important
to you it is important to me yeah
without social media
gianni when Renee got candid about
handling their personal lives in the
spotlight well how do you manage all of
that I just use alcohol ha ha ha ha if
it's really unimportant yeah unnecessary
and makes a person's life way more
interesting and colorful than it is in
truth because it depends on the day and
circumstances and what becomes necessary
media scrutiny aside there's no denying
Renee is killing it after taking a 6
year break from Hollywood she's back
with several new films including her
latest the whole truth and Bridget
Jones's baby she attended the London
premiere in September with her man Doyle
Bramhall is it safe to say your
happiest you've ever been I'm definitely
in a happy phase of my life
yeah whatever tribute into maturity
maturity